H-h-he- h ow's it going everyone?
I mean... bros..
**lols**
My name is.. PEEEEEWDIE PIE.
Once again, a commentary in Swedish.
This it to delighting, gives my belly butterflies.
I have a very...
Game: I CAN SEE YOU! >:D
But, no. I don't like that :(
Not when.. oooh.
Is there somebody there?
God, that's spooky!
Ehrm, I know that not everyone loves that I do commentary in Swedish.
Which I can understand, If I watched some Let's Player
Who speaks in Russian, Deutch, then I'm all like:
Hallo? I mean like what is he doing? I don't understand a thing.
Ehrm, but that will only be this series.
Ah!
Ah ah ah!
Uh, uhj!
STOP! STOP!
Knock it of, ffs. What did I do?
Oh no, no. Goddamn pussy, goddamn pussy, goddamn pussy, goddamn pussy.
AAAH! AAAH! AAAAH!
Yesyesyesyesyesyesyesyesyesyes.
That was fun! Yes what fun!
Hi! :D Martin is that you?
Martin, how delightful!
Martin: ???????????????
Pewdiepie: ????????????
Finde der laten, NU!
What the hell???
Fucking fun, fucking nice.
Erhm, we'll launch another custom story in Swedish!
So we have something at least. Alright see you soon, bye!
Okay, here we are. Barrels...
What the hell is their name in Swedish?
BARRELS!!! Barrels, I hate you!
Gtfo, you fucking barrels!
Heey! Okay, then we'll go here.
Aha, you're looking at that. Lovely! Hallo?
Aah, nicely bugged scare. *lols*
That did not go as planned, you know. Ah, let's keep going.
The key was inside maybe. But he's in the way, how the hell can I open?
Ah, okay! Heey! A lantern, lovely! Very lovely. Appreciated!
Still can't progess, can it be here?
STOP STARING AT THEM YOU GAY!
Just kidding, nothing wrong with gay.
Okay, Mr Chair what are you doing?
Herr Stol: Pewdie! I'm upside down! Oh no! no oh no...
Herr Stol: Please put me down! **Activates Chair Mode**
Erhm, where do we have the key? Where do we have the key?
There, we have the key! Pressed.. "Brand New Key" c:
**Lols** Feels good, it's always a rusty key!
Feels a lot better having a new key, feels fresh!
BARREL! It's HUGE, STEPHANO!
You're also giagantic, I like it c:
And that is.. I don't know what I should say...
We can jump down there, but I don't think it's a good idea.
STEPHANO! You're holy! You're a god!
**Bathes in his glory** Stephanoo c':
Mkay, Aah! Skully! How you doing?
Alright, ah .. Barrels...
What the hell..
Alright... c: **lols**
Uhm, this guy doesn't seem to know how to fix his scares..
Aaah Jesus! :D Skully.. looking good there!
Oil, for me? Are we going down here?
Geronimo! I did it! I fucking did it.
Oh no!
**lols** Damn what a stupid map.
Ah! NO! NO YOU'RE NOT COMING WITH ME!
I don't trust any of you!
AH! Oh.. shi--- cock!
GET AWAY FROM HERE! STOP FOLLOWING ME!
Ugh D:
The key to the third... Hey how you doing? See you later? :D
He he, okay. I'm out of here!
Uh, uh, okay the third door..
Ah, we're checking these to for the sake of lol.
The sake of lol.... LOL!
Okay, I'm sorry... There was nothing...
Ah come on.. I think, ah it's too late!
He-Hey! :D Sup? Okay, I'm just going over here..
Ah, knock it off goddamnit! Runrunrunrun!
AAAAAH D: That hurt!
Straight to the shoulder **sound effect** Aah pussy to!
Don't like that.. don't like that.. The shoulder, it fucking hurts :(
I mean okay, if he hits me softly on girl. (Wtf?)
You know, okay ... **lols** Lets go to the third door then.
Hallo? Anyone here? OPEN FFS!
Hallo? Aaah, come on!
Gtfo you fucking... I don't trust you!
KNOCK IT OF FFS, I DON'T TRUST YOU!
Uh-oh, happens every day.. every Thirsday. Following the footsteps.
**Monster moans**
He's horny... he's horny as hell!
Uh oh! Where the hell should I go then? Heuh D:
Alright here we have oil.. Give me oil!
If you're reading this note that means you've survived so far. You're almost there, keep progressing.
OH NO, THE FUCKING COCK OF HELL!
Pussypussypussypussypussy! Ha-haaa! :D
I made it myself! :D Yeaaah, speaking english I don't know why. :P **lols**
Okay, very lovely! Wonderful! Wunderbar!
Come on! Load ffs.
OH NO :( FUCK!
Aigh, no, now it's enough. That wasn't funny.. noot funny!
The wrath of the fucking vagina.
**breathes out** Okay, we stop it there.
**lols** URGHHAAa uhm, I actually think this is the last Swedish one I make. (for now)
There are some complaining, but I know a lot of people enjoy it so I wanted to make one more.
Okay, that was it. Brofist, like, fav, it helps, you know. And we'll see eachother tomorrow.
With a new video, lovely. God how much fun we have together you and I.
I think it's great what we have together here you and I.
**lols** Brofist! Bye! :D